el cierre de gobierno un panorama
temible en la política estadounidense
que amenaza justamente ahora cuando el
presidente joe biden busca la aprobación
de su agenda económica la cual incluye
un incremento del gasto social un
presupuesto de 35 billones de dólares
además se prevé que la cámara de
representantes vote una ley de
infraestructuras de 1.2 billones de
dólares que ya ha recibido el visto
bueno del senado todo esto debe suceder
antes de la medianoche del jueves de lo
contrario el gobierno enfrenta
nuevamente la posibilidad de un cierre
parcial y que significa que el gobierno
de eeuu cierre si la iniciativa
presupuestaria de bailén es rechazada el
gobierno se queda sin dinero esto quiere
decir que los trabajadores federales
considerados no esenciales dejarían de
recibir fondos las funciones
gubernamentales no esenciales se
congelan se cierran agencias federales
oficinas de visas y pasaportes así como
museos y parques nacionales
además del plan presupuestario
demócratas y republicanos deben acordar
la elevación del techo de la deuda de
eeuu que supera actualmente los 28
billones de dólares y que es el límite
de endeudamiento establecido este año
particularmente se estimó que el país
llegaría a su límite de deuda a finales
de octubre debido a que la pandemia de
kobe 19 provocó gastos mayores un cierre
del gobierno no es algo nuevo en la
economía más grande del mundo desde 1981
el gobierno estadounidense ha enfrentado
14 cierres de distinta duración el
último ocurrido en 2019 bajo la
presidencia de donald trump duró 35 días